[музика]
позаду мене підприємство на якому я
працюю вже 5 років Я ще молодий і свій
професійний шлях починав з училища мене
звати Сергій і я токар
за цим станком Я працюю щодня по 6 годин
в роботі головне дисципліна і точність Я
люблю працювати з металом я його ніби
відчуваю працювати почав ще на другому
курсі училища прийшов сюди на практику
так і залишився Мені подобається я
взагалі в училищі відмінником був ці
технічні предмети мені давались А от моє
перше болти були не надто охайні я
помилявся в діаметрі пам'ятаю тоді
боявся що мене покарають але ні навчили
Зараз у мене звичайно таких помилок не
буває
здебільшого Це звісно заслуга мо майстра
він буквально навчив мене всього і
навичкам і ставлення до роботи я йому
зобов'язаний Ну і всій групі моїй
колектив був невеликий але справжній
А ще знаєте приємно з моїх деталей
роблять мости великі будівлі і навіть
судно то виходить що міста України
відбудовуються і розвиваються завдяки
мені
Ну я щасливий що все працює як треба